تتبادل أوكرانيا وروسيا الاتهامات
بشن هجمات جوية
خلال الليل. يقول المسؤولون الروس إنهم
دمروا عدة طائرات بدون طيار أوكرانية
فوق البحر الأسود واحتلوا شبه جزيرة القرم،
لكن عددًا قليلًا منها ألحق أضرارًا بالمباني في
منطقة كورسك، وفي هذه الأثناء
تقول أوكرانيا إن روسيا أطلقت أكثر من 30 طائرة بدون طيار.
أنا والصواريخ على
منطقة أوديسا يقول المسؤولون إن معظمها تم إسقاطه
لكن روسيا ضربت
البنية التحتية لميناء أوديسا وتسببت في حريق في
فندق لم يكن قيد التشغيل،
وبينما وقعت الهجمات بعد أن
أنهى الرئيس الأوكراني رحلة إلى
الولايات المتحدة وكندا  حيث حصل على
دعم إضافي بما في ذلك
اتفاق بين كييف وواشنطن
لإنتاج الأسلحة معًا،
لدينا قرار تاريخي من قبل الولايات المتحدة
للإنتاج المشترك للأسلحة وأنظمة الدفاع
بما في ذلك الدفاع الجوي، وهذا
شيء كان خيالًا مطلقًا
حتى وقت قريب ولكنه سيصبح
حقيقة  سنجعل الأمر حقيقة
تتابع كلير سيباستيان من سي إن إن جميع
التطورات من لندن، يوم جيد،
ليلة مرعبة في
مدينة أوديسا الساحلية الأوكرانية، ماذا
يمكنك أن تخبرنا أكثر من ذلك،
نعم صباح الخير يا ليلى، أعتقد
أنه من المهم فهم السياق
المحيط  أوديسا لأن هذه
ثالث أكبر مدينة في أوكرانيا تعرضت
لقصف منتظم جدًا منذ يوليو عندما
انسحبت روسيا من مبادرة حبوب البحر الأسود تلك،
نرى هذا الصباح أه
الضرر كبير إلى حد ما،
محطة الركاب أه تم تدميرها
وفقًا لأوكرانيا فندق قريب يحرق
أيضًا مخازن الحبوب أه  ضربت أيضًا
مرافق تخزين خضراء، ومن الواضح أن هذا
جزء من نمط تعرضت أوديسا للضرب
عدة مرات الآن، ويأتي هذا في الوقت الذي
تحاول فيه أوكرانيا توفير
ممرات بحرية آمنة من جانب واحد للسفن لإخراج
حبوبها إلى السوق العالمية، ويأتي أيضًا
كما تفعل روسيا نفسها  تصدير
كميات قياسية من القمح، مما يعني الاستفادة بشكل أساسي
من حقيقة أن هذا
التعطيل يتسبب في قيام أوكرانيا بتصدير كميات
أقل من القمح إلى السوق العالمية، وهو أمر
بالغ الأهمية للغاية، أه لمشاهدته في سياق سيء،
هذا ليس هدفًا عسكريًا، هذا
هجوم على اقتصاد أوكرانيا، وكما أنا
قالت ليلى إن المزيد من البنية التحتية للحبوب ضربت هذا
الصباح ليلى وشكرًا كلير على
توضيح ذلك بالنسبة لنا الآن،
أعلن الرئيس زيلينسكي، الذي عاد لتوه من الولايات المتحدة وكندا، عن
اتفاق مشترك لإنتاج الأسلحة بين
الولايات المتحدة وأوكرانيا، ما الذي نعرفه بالضبط
عن هذه الصفقة،
نعم لا نعرفها  'لا أعرف بالضبط ما هو الشكل الذي
سيتخذه هذا الأمر في الوقت الحالي الذي
وصفه الرئيس زيلينسكي بالطبع بأنه تاريخي
أه لقد قال في الواقع يوم الجمعة إن
العديد من اتفاقيات التعاون أه
قد تم التوقيع عليها بالفعل من قبل
أحد وزرائه أه عندما كانوا
في الولايات المتحدة وقد تم التعاون  لقد
بدأ بالفعل بالفعل،
قال الرئيس بايدن إن الولايات المتحدة ستستضيف
مؤتمرًا في الخريف لجمع
ممثلين عن
صناعة الدفاع الأوكرانية وصناعة الدفاع الأمريكية
والحكومات أيضًا حتى
يتمكنوا من معرفة نوع التنسيق الذي
رأيناه.  مثل هذا مع
المشاريع المشتركة لشركات الدفاع الأوروبية التي يتم إنشاؤها في أوكرانيا والتي تعمل
معًا في أشياء مختلفة ومن الواضح
بالنسبة لأوكرانيا أن الأولوية الرئيسية الآن على
المدى المتوسط ​​والطويل هي تعزيز
صناعتها الدفاعية الخاصة لإنشاء
رادع وأيضًا حتى يمكن أن تكون كذلك  وأقل
اعتماداً على حلفائها الغربيين